There are a few moments in
the life of an institution
that are historic.
This is one of those
very rare moments.
The Living Village is an
expression of a phenomenon
that has been studied by
generations of psychologists
and other social scientists,
as well as by scholars
of divinity and religion.
And that is, hope.
It is historic for Yale
Divinity School,
not only because it will alter
the physical structure
of the school,
but it will set an agenda
for the educational program
of the school
that will train students
as apostles of the environment.
I've waited a long time
to say this line.
I want to reverse the lyrics
of Joni Mitchell's song.
They tore down paradise
to put up a parking lot.
It is time to tear up a
parking lot
to put up paradise.